[Music]
Hello friends and welcome to the destiny
Destiny's weekly destiny Destiny at 2
p.m. Destiny right here on destiny.com
Destiny Desy Destiny hey video games
specifically the one specifically
Destiny because that's all anyone's
everever talking about Destiny it's
because hey there's a video game that's
like exciting to be talking about that
we've heard about for ages which you
guys all over the place played for like
a millionaires yesterday we all did we
all did yeah that was pretty fun you
Jokers were in at like 5: in the morning
though right we were mhm we did the 5
a.m. shift it end up at 14 hours I think
that I was there for eight of them cool
really nine oh God okay I got off easy
eight I did like four got you did like
two STS of three didn't you no we didn't
do three on the last one is it the kind
of game you should play that wasn't what
getting drunk no I was still here is it
the kind of game you should play for 14
hours out of stretch I don't think so no
I don't think so either what game is
though that's that's craziness I I once
completed BioShock Infinite in that much
time because I was coming here I was
coming to live in America for a month
and I needed to just have it finished
because my PC was stuck in UK so I had
to Barrel through it and it was awful
and you just like like broke you down
like you're you have all these racist
sympathies and you're like questioning
all your World Views you're coming to
America it just really sets you off yeah
yeah exactly weird terrible you arrived
here very strange I did I I've continued
to be strange consistently since I
arrived we're going to talk about
Destiny later but uh clearly either you
guys have accidentally just come both in
your hockey regalia or we got ourselves
a game
on it's Sports Game season uh well
second at the Block on your giant
novelty shirts what team are what team
are you here as Mary Kish these are the
Buffalo Sabers Mary the great one Kish
I'm from Buffalo so this is my home team
I'm the only East Coast mother in here
so oh he's he's from the East Coast yeah
come on he's East Coast Massachusetts no
Bruins East Coast right right the least
least my country is so small that I'm
basically from every Coast thanks for
leaving me hanging as well you jerk Eric
Iceman who are you with I am the San
Jose Sharks okay sharks synonymous with
ice makes lot you're a gross fish and
Ice sharks you don't have any
allegiances to our teams we don't play
on the we have a game where we don't
play on ice called harling which is so
it's unprofessional oh yeah playing on
the street corner outside bars at 3:
a.m. and we don't want nice work I think
we make fun of those games when we're
playing games well well I'm going to
make fun of you cuz I have a feeling
Eric Tay is going to take you to school
I've I've had this coming for some time
now but my pride won't allow me to not
play Mary you are good at NHL but
unfortunately for you Eric Tay is maybe
quite a bit better you were the office
Pro he's good at everything I'm all
right at this game I I mean like I've
played any a lot he's too good I've
played a lot of like NHL games
throughout like growing up I haven't
stuck to the series necessarily but just
knowing the game like knowing the sport
and like watching the sport helps you
like FIFA for you right like you watch
soccer all the time so you can make
plays you can see the pitch better like
and do things like appreciation of the
scort exactly mayos games all the time
too I do I do I've I've been to sharks
games let's get into this guys yeah I'm
ready do a hockey I was just showing
some of the stats cuz some people like
looking at them
that no don't just go away from that I
don't want to see really high numbers
why are they higher than the San Jose
numbers because what does that won the
Stanley Cup oh they won the Stanley Cup
did the San Jose team do that
ever oh shoot the Kings win does does
there a mini game where there's riots
outside of E3 or if they lose my
controller just T secret is to just
select C play for yeah he doesn't want
to play anymore what are you yeah I just
instaed
production the controllers cropped out I
think it might have died no I'll fix it
and I'll play I used play NHL 94 all the
time I also wanted to make it clear just
how
low my saber STS are in case it has any
bearing on possibly what happens during
the game yeah it's one of the lower ones
well we wait for for Batteries to come
in here's your advantage well we wait
for Batteries to come in Mary we you got
to listen
in front you oh yeah you might have
noticed this piece of paper that kind of
looks like a resume but it's actually in
fact uh a list of all the things that
are missing um since nhl1 14 which a lot
of people have been pretty frustrated
with pay no attention to any noises that
you might hear um you know it's
fascinating I was like looking up a lot
of the features that were missing to see
like how bad it was or you know if it's
they're like minor issues and it's it's
a legitimate list straight so we had NHL
14 last year was not on nextg consoles
this is the first like Xbox One PS4 NHL
and this thing Happ FIFA as well all of
this stuff go for it okay uh no GM
connected no online team play no EA
Sports hockey league no EA Sports Arena
no online shootouts live the life be a
legend Winter Classic it's all gone win
no create a team um there's no custom
camera option there the only way it is
no cre team there's no these even like
little things there's no top three stars
at the end of the game some of this
stuff is going to be really yeah that's
a bit weird and it's a very small thing
so a lot of this stuff is going to be
added in uh later I believe that they've
mentioned there will be a patch in
October where they're going to be adding
a lot of these uh additional features
from you know being able to play uh
online team play is a huge one so like
which like you can only play one onone
that's right so like in online team play
it's like 12 people online can all play
as each individual player is really cool
they're going to be adding that in uh in
the patch that's a bit messed up uh so
this stuff happened to FIFA last year
where the NextGen one didn't have like
some really peculiar stuff like
tournament mode which was basically a
way of just like playing the world cup
or the Premier League without like
having to go into career mode was
inexplicably not there how complicated
can that be to just keep it's weird
stuff like you couldn't do unranked
friendlies like okay there was like four
different online modes but you couldn't
do that so it's weird I I guess this is
what happens when you've got like these
massive teams who are suddenly having to
be split in the middle to make stuff for
next gen and and and previous gen yeah
it's it's it's a bummer that they that
they're doing that I I mean like I said
there is a patch where they're going to
be putting some of the features back in
and I would suggest um giving them your
money in the
patch because I you know when until the
game is there I wouldn't really probably
pay for it until it's a full game see
the way it's going there's no hard date
for a patch and like just cuz they say a
patch is coming does not mean a patch is
coming usually it does but when will it
come will it come in October like when
they say will it come in December will
it come in February like that and this
EA remember what happened with
Battlefield 4 where that stuff didn't
some of it didn't ever materialize and
the other thing I wonder is I wonder did
they have to put this out on the date
because of Licensing stuff like they
probably could have held off and up put
that's a rumor yeah there's also um like
the fear because they've had issues with
other games where um online has been
broken I mean like look at some of the
other EA Games maybe they just did
wanted to make sure it wasn't broken a
reasonable fear I suppose well I guess
in this you know head video game website
headline World perhaps it's better the
headline it doesn't have multiplayer is
a bit better than yo this game is
multiplayer player totally broken uh
it's yeah anyway we're on to the
ice all right the saers pushing across
the blue line going the outside going
for a really low percentage shot my very
few shots on goal trying to get trying
to get the one timer action that's
that's always the key
right fell down Burns you're bigger than
that guy to be fair the saber fell down
first I have more love in the game oh my
God you kicked it from me I didn't know
you check there's all kinds of checks in
hockey body check stick check poke check
kick check blade check head check oh no
check stolen butt check elbow check
check check get out of my freaking
way testing Joi from distance here
that's anti Mami yeah because his
defense could use little spin move
doesn't happen go go go go icing Icing a
little line icing for Europeans was like
the off side over here your guys must be
cold for figure it out you need the
icing was pretty important like the way
they changed it cuz it prevents a lot of
injuries I have a delayed penalty coming
to me oh M it up it is ring the ball
baby oh my gosh that felt really good oh
man I'm really I'm as surprised as
everyone here here we go here's an upset
oh man it's that home it's that home
field advantage I want to make it clear
Eric creamed me
yesterday I think what you need to make
clear at this point is that was a goal
I'm impressed with myself you have one
goal to Eric's zero this is beautiful
though like let's end the
segment that's NHL 15 everybody I did it
the crowd looks really good although it
does seem to be the same dude this game
looks so good it is good and I don't
know if you guys saw but the announcers
are live announcers it's like real video
it is a bit weird but it looks good I
think it it's a testament to how good
the game looks wa wait it's it's real
video like of actual dudes who were
films it's like on green screen it looks
like it's on green screen oh that's the
dumbest we got to see some of that going
for it uh maybe get it feel like I'm
going to get whooped oh this is great oh
stood up stood up against the board he's
prot no he's protecting the p are get
off my butt oh man two open in front of
the
net big sa f f f f fight it's triangle y
also known as there we go I Swit I you
got you got to like I think you have to
raise it over the course of the game you
got to keep the anger building up um and
then and then you punch when the gloves
come off fighting is important though in
it is actually raises I believe stats of
the individual player I hate I think
it's the dumbest fighting it's so dumb
no okay I'll tell you I'll tell you why
fighting is important fighting is
important because if the refs don't do
their jobs in terms of like oh Jesus in
terms of like making calls and stuff
like that protecting the players you
have to be able to protect your players
and so by having that is some that is
some old oh how school that is you can
apply that to every sport if the refs
aren't going to do it we're going to
enforce it ourselves yeah [__] no come
on get away from me get away from me
uhoh that's not good that's not good
that was
bad oh that was a good that was a good
Pat that was a good pass my passes are
oh my God D him on the ground his helmet
is off he's still stay hmd how does that
have penalty uhoh uhoh what is even
going on I'm going after goalie you just
running my people over give [__] about
your people listen the thug oh my God
two on one go goalie be a goalie do a
goalie do that goalie thing that you
guys are good at we got some distraction
questions primed from the the twitch
chat and Gamespot chat noodle legs asks
have the goalie reactions been improved
uh they used to be pretty brutal in the
past does it seem that way um maybe you
say they were too good before oh really
yeah how do you feel about them they
they're pretty strong it is hard to make
a goal I would say you would say that
score
one's coming up big with the D I think
we're going to finish this after the
first quarter no really yes eight
seconds left this is it this is your
last chance for the score no he gets
shut down and that's it I can't believe
it why would we have the J out
there victory this is what the Sharks do
when they want to intimidate players no
this is power play this
power really lame and I just want you
guys to know you what is yours what is
your Buffalo saber power
play I think it's the double bird
that's just what I do whenever whenever
I'm on the
Megatron godam it godamn it
yeah nice work K NHL 15 review coming
soon when's the review coming up who's
doing it um it is should be up today
okay cool NHL 15 review coming soon I
wonder if we'll have to do a review in
progress for that because it's clearly
not finished yet I guess we'll find
there pretty soon if they ship it that
way fired that's that's on them you know
cuz then good argument of like a moo or
an MMO right like you can all the patch
stuff doesn't count
that you suck Eric te I know you're
better at Destiny we'll get you back on
for that later on uh but right away now
we're gonna have Mark Walton on from the
UK R pretty soon but first of all in the
meantime here's a trailer for alien on
isolation
aliens
[Music]
oh
we like to talk about video games here
in the lobby what would it being a video
game website but hey Mark Walton's here
and a bunch of Apple news done happened
yes how you doing my friend good good to
see you how's London how's London yeah
um not as nice as San Francisco is at
the moment it's very sunny here oh is
not weather's not too good bu uh no it's
kind of grously and horrible it's London
it's London weather you're here in a
special secret mission right now right I
am here on a secret special mission that
I unfortunately can't talk about
entirely but I'm I'm here for a big Tech
event that isn't the Apple event okay um
and they're going to be some cool gaming
Hardware things some good news to look
out for in the next couple weeks okay
looking forward to it but right now
there was Apple news and looking at your
your wonderful tablet here I see a watch
what the goddamn hell happened today uh
so there were loads there was a lot of
announcements on the Apple thing I mean
obviously the one that everyone's going
to talk about it's not so much a gaming
thing but we'll quickly go through it is
the Apple watch it's a smartwatch
everyone loves SmartWatches right anyone
I know I love mine oh no am I the only
one wearing an actual watch right now
yeah yes okay because it's 2014 watch is
a cool okay this is a cool watch it's
stylish yeah right are these watches
stylish that's arguable right beauty is
in the eye of the beholder you know I
think they look quite cool but I think
the big thing is it's Square not round
right right everyone's like oh the
Motorola one that's round this is square
it does lots of cool stuff it has
Fitness stuff on it it's made of really
expensive stuff it's going to cost like
350 bucks wait is that a feature what
it's going to cost 350 bucks I think it
was 350 don't quote me on that like 350
or 39 I think that's like the starting
model that's the starting model for the
stainless steel one there's an aluminium
one for sports fiends aluminum for
Americans yes that would be incorrect
and they would uh it's true and uh it's
spelled aluminum huh it's spelled
aluminum here it is yeah swear to God we
just straight up rcon that spell
ridiculous and there's one more that's
made of 18 karat gold really yeah great
that's the Dr Dre model so what to do
like why would you want to have this in
your hand well look at the end of the
day right with the Smartwatch stuff a
lot of them they're sort of work in
progress right there's not a lot of
stuff going on with them uh this one you
know there's the usual Fitness stuff um
there's like maps on it you can like
like take calls on it you can look at
your tweets you can look at all the
Facebook stuff you know I think the
difference with the Apple One compared
to the others it's much better
integrated the OS looks fun and it's got
this uh the thing with it is a new
interface it's got like this digital
Crown basically you know like on a watch
you have like the tney thing yeah use
that to zoom in and out okay you know
it's really simple I know it sounds
really obvious there it is yeah no no
one yeah but no one else has done that
right so I mean it's yeah it sounds like
a cool interface I like the one where
you can basic you like connect to
someone else's you can send them the
little little Doodles that you just draw
on look at this nonsense watch porn is
watch it is totally watch slow motion
hot watch
magnets yeah yeah you can you can send
Doodles you can send like your own
heartbeat so you could feel someone's
heartbeat someone else's heartbeat
coming through your it's got like um
this um like a of Love finally no I know
how long were we waiting for this no
it's got like a haptic uh like motor
thing in it so instead of like vibrating
it's sort of supposed to feel like it
just Taps you gently okay yeah can I
play like Angry Birds by like like
flicking my wrist up like every couple
of seconds or sorry not Angry Birds
Flappy Bird Flappy Bird no you can't do
that but you can play games on the new
iPhone 6 or iPhone 6 plus a new phone
great my current phone is even more old
now yes every day Danny yeah I know so
iPhone 6 iPhone 6 Plus for I guess the
wow okay you need a new phone you need
to fix that bad boy you're going to need
a lot of money to buy an iPhone 6 or
iPhone 6 Plus like if you get one
unlocked it's well it's a lot okay yeah
it's a lot of money um I think I I
believe it it goes well up to like $900
and something dolls if you if you want
it unlocked without a contract for the8
Gig model okay for the iPhone 6 Plus um
so I guess the big thing with this for
games is that it's got a new A8
processor it's got this new API which
they announced a while ago but is
designed to work with the new A8
processor which basically means lowlevel
access to the hardware you get really
nice fancy graphics and they wield out
uh Infinity Blade 3 it wasn't infin it
wasn't Infinity Blade 3 it was super
evil Mega Corp although I wouldn't have
been
surprised if it was uh Infinity Blade 3
no it was a game called vain Glory which
they were saying 60 frames per second
there was a little bit of a dig uh
towards the nextg consoles where you
know they were saying like this runs at
a higher resolution than the nextg
consoles and it's a phone you know so
the play Destiny get Destiny on it
doesn't play Destiny you get the destiny
app on it why do we even have it on this
week's show if it doesn't play Destiny
Destiny only stream clearly I'm the only
man in the world that hasn't played
Destiny yeah probably yeah I think so
we'll probably fix that later on today h
Chris you don't want to watch is this is
this finally going to get you out of
your watch apathy no uh I don't I've
never really want to watch so having the
thing on the wrist is like a barrier for
me uh I don't know what I would use it
for honestly kind sounds at what time it
is like okay let me just check what time
it is I've got oh yep sure it's that
time I see I like being able to check on
my wrist for the watch right I mean it's
one of those things you're like oh yeah
very cool but what if like somebody
calls you and your phone rings in your
pocket and your fraking wrist Wing rings
are you going to be that guy who's like
like like yes starf come in Daniel yes
hello don't you want it to be the future
damn it okay like the future should be
now glass holes what are we going to
call these people wrist holes look okay
watch Holes let's work on it we all
laughed at like the iPad when that was
announced we were like no one's going to
want one of those big I for touch
whatever look what happened I mean
admittedly tablet sales have stagnated
and are going down but okay for a little
while tablets were huge okay yeah but
you could okay say the same thing about
like that's the argument people used for
like the Wii U about the Wii
and also and also you could say the same
thing about like Google Glass yeah you
could say that that's not muchal item
look at the end of the day I mean for
for me the watch it looks cool I'm the
the only stipulation with it is that you
need um an iOS device so you need an
iPhone 5 or higher to use it I actually
be on you or just you just need to sync
it occasionally it needs to I think they
need to they work together so that
they're sort of a pairing they need to
be together which sucks for me cuz I
switched to Android like last year
really um but now I'm like I kind of
want the damn watch and I'm going to
switch have they said what the battery
life is no they haven't said what the
battery life a reason why they haven't
said that yet absolutely absolutely cuz
everyone was like what's the battery
life on this thing and just like stun
silence it's also not out until 2015 oh
really yeah start start of the year um
so you know uh the iPhones are actually
out much sooner I believe it's next week
or the week after so you can go stand in
line get yourself an iPhone 6 Plus 1080p
display bam it's massive is it really
yes okay it it's big it's like Galaxy
Note big and get your pre-orders in for
app can that even fit in a human pocket
it can fit in a human pocket but there
is a smaller one there's a 4.7 in one
you can get Mark Mark gets gets this in
his pocket this is this is this is a
Surface 3 making me the second person in
the world to own a surface 3 apart from
Kevin vanard okay um so yeah great nice
work any else on the Apple front well
not really I mean look at the end of the
day I'm quite I'm quite excited I've
been meaning to switch back to Apple for
a little while and I wanted a bigger
screen phone maybe not as big as that
1080p one which you know but you know at
the end day it's a usual app of stuff
better cameras it looks sexy everyone's
going to want one it costs a fortune
there you go Apple get your preorders in
now awesome mark wton thank you very
much for coming on no worries we're
going to talk about Destiny so you have
no place on this couch I have no place
on this so we'll be back in a couple of
minutes H first of all we're going to
check out the trailer for Sky Forge a
game that I feel like has been coming
out for a million years let's check it
out
the Paladin is a Fearless Warrior and
defender of the oppressed filled with
righteous anger he faces the enemy head
on protecting his allies and drawing
attackers away from them skillfully
wielding his sword he charges into the
thick of battle no danger can make
Paladin Retreat his safety is ured with
the protection of his Celestial
Shield waves of Holiness will draw
Paladin's enemies to him where he will
call down a Divine Scourge upon
them in an instant the celestial Shield
will explode and the shock wave will
knock stunned enemies from their feet if
enemies fail to turn their backs and
flee he will unleash his ultimate Fury
summoning thunder and lightning to
strike opponents
down when the battle ends the Paladin's
wounds will be the first to heal and he
will be ready for the next fight his
Justice blade will strike the enemies
again and none will escape his punishing
bols no enemy skills can match the
Glorious figure of the Paladin as he
Soares to the heavens tearing through
hostile spells to bring his righteous
might down upon his
enemies paladins are no stranger to the
heat of battle they enjoy bloody fights
and dramatic combo
attacks want to know more visit Skyforge
Destiny finally came out yesterday and
we had a bunch of Gamespot editors
playing it all day long something stupid
like 15 hours here are three of them
Mary Kish Eric Tay Chris Waters hey
let's talk about First Impressions it's
been a day the review in progress on
went up on Gamespot today Kevin vard's
full review is going to be up later in
the week H there's a video review going
up in a couple of minutes as well uh but
first of all you guys's First
Impressions on it um you played for a
lot of time yesterday like yeah like
each of you play for about six hours
each is that right nine nine yeah how
for me okay six as well all right first
impressions right out the gate uh it
feels to me like Destiny would be like
the hottest thing like so revolutionary
if I hadn't played if you know I didn't
know about its predecessors if I hadn't
played bunch of Halo a bunch of
Borderlands a bunch of other firstperson
Shooters if I was someone who was like
Hey next gen console seems kind of cool
what can I play on it a shooter is neat
Destiny is one I see on the buses cool
let me play it like it does a lot of
stuff in like a very polished uh very
well executed way uh but it doesn't
really get exciting for I feel like for
me until well into the game until like
hours into it because of difficulty or
just because difficulty is a part of it
you know difficulty is definitely a part
like when we were taking on in the like
towards the end we were playing uh very
you know very hard it was like a few
levels enemies were a few levels above
our level we had to use all our weapons
we had to use our abilities we had be
nimble we had to support each other we
yeah like all that stuff started
clicking but before that wasn't really
happening so I think I feel like that
runup you know for me is it's like you
know it's kind of like going through the
motions the the the gear you get is not
exciting the the enemies you're facing
are kind of pushovers but if you're you
know if this is your first kind of
experience in this kind of game then I
think that runup is good like I think
people need that so I feel like that's
sort of where they've how they've
calibrated it Mary you played a lot of
boorder right yeah I loved Borderlands
especially you know the second one play
the crap out of it I remember when you
were playing yesterday one of the things
that you were giving out about which I
actually hadn't even considered is that
the the drops off the buses and stuff
are kind of lame they are you know this
is something like I constantly compare
it to Borderlands because that's you
know the easiest comparison to make for
me and you know what makes it fun are
the people that you play with you have
so much fun playing with your friends
and you enjoy taking down these massive
bosses and losing you honestly have a
really good time trying again changing
up your weapons and trying a different
tactic but the reward in Borderlands was
always the bigger the boss the better
the drop now sometimes even important
because they are randomized right
sometimes you don't get a good drop and
it pisses you off because you work
really hard for that drop I want to see
a good gun more often than not though
you do get rewarded for that not so much
in Destiny um you pretty much don't get
drops from the bosses besides like ammo
uh you find chests sometimes after the
drop but you got to be really quick
because after you like achieve your goal
you get like what 25 seconds to like run
around and like see any crates and hope
that you get the within a story Mission
yeah because the mission kind of it it
says like Mission complet it sends you
back no you can go back later and find
the same chest and uh that happened to
me I got I opened the chest like right
as my 30 you like I got it faded black
and I didn't didn't get my piece it
really sucks but like you can go back to
it but I I would have loved to see more
drops to me that is a part of what makes
that style of game so enjoyable is uh I
want to see the next gun I have a sweet
gun I love it now I want the next one
you get gun crazy that's kind of what's
so interesting about that I find myself
to be gun crazy when I play them this is
the this is the footage they'll play
back on the news when you eventually R
she was such a nice girl T you actually
completed the main story stuff this
morning right yeah I finished it this
morning um I there's still like one
other story Quest that have to do but I
guess that was like the actual like last
level for story no no spoilers but what
did you what did you think about how it
wrapped up as it were um I mean doesn't
wrap up even it it's it's kind of like a
movie right it doesn't really ever end
right so movies End Eric well okay fine
not the story you know those movies with
trilogies and whatnot you know they they
always find a way to Loop it back around
and like okay there's more to explore
and I I for me personally going through
the motions of playing the whole like up
to now I would say the beginning part
like Chris said it's kind of just like H
this is kind of tedious a little bit
maybe because we play beta too I don't
know um but once I started getting like
further along and even for yourself it's
like some of the some of the missions
get a bit harder you guys have to do
more tactical stuff together um and in
terms of the guns I don't want to spoil
too much but you know there's it looks
like there's possible more in possibly
more interesting types of weapons in the
future that we haven't really seen yet
hopefully I'm not blowing that out of
proportion but for me I have like one
new thing that is like totally kind of
not totally but it's different from what
we've seen from that first part of it
like up until yesterday so and that made
me excited so I'm I'm I'm also curious
about all the raids the endgame stuff
like because that's when the game starts
right yeah they kept saying that right
it like starts at level 20 what level
were you by the time you finished uh I
was 17 no I was right about to TI to 17
so I was 16 the mission was about 18 we
weren't that far off then we stopped
doing the the stream yesterday did
anyone play on their own
I stage you did I did last night how did
you find playing it on your own um so
it's interesting because it's easier
obviously there's less mobs there's less
for you to deal with however you're
punished more if you die there's no one
to resurrect you so you startle over
that happened to me a couple times a day
where I just got a little too greedy to
a little bit too overzealous and I was
just like I'm going to punch this guy I
was like nope he punched me and I died
and I was like 40% through that mission
it's like cocky yeah it's like start
start all over cuz there's no one else
to resurrect it bumps you back to the
sort of beginning of the area that's
like you know resurrecting limited right
that stuff that sort of kicks in when
you know you're entering sort of an
action stretch um can we talk about one
thing we haven't really touched on so
far this game looks so good is beautiful
and going to different planets and like
different environments and just like
exploring it was something we actually
didn't end up taking a lot of time to do
on the stream yesterday because we were
kind of like go go go see new stuff see
new stuff get level up level up uh like
taking the time to just kind of like
look at sky boxes look at you know look
at the look at the corridors you're
going through to get to the boss and
like today I was going through one that
was like this caves with these glowing
crystals and like this flowing
shimmering water that was kind of this
strange color and then I got closer to
where the boss was and there were these
piles of Bones like thousands of
Bones holy crap what the hell like
thousands of Bones oh my God like it's
it's a and it's it's a gorgeous game so
that is one thing that nobody argues
with right I mean there's all these
people saying it sucks or it's amazing
it's the best game one thing that people
really don't argue with is it is a
beautiful game they've done a tremendous
job with the environment with the
weather it sprinkles down on I feel like
like this this at least hits the bar the
next game should be hitting like I don't
find this toes sorry yeah next gen games
I don't find this to be any more
beautiful than something like Infamous
Second Son the one thing that stuck out
for me is regardless of the fact that it
does look good and the Sky Box and all
that stuff look great the actual Worlds
the places themselves I found kind of
soulless and Kevin said as much in his
uh in his early riew progress yeah like
these places feel like instances rather
than actual places which I found a
little bit disappointing I feel like
there you know I think there's a way to
play a game and there's a way for a game
to encourage you to play that allows you
to sort of sit down in the world a
little bit you know so for example this
what we're seeing now is on Venus uh
doing a doing Patrol so you're just you
just pick up a mission and that you're
in a certain area you know doing a bunch
of stuff fighting a bunch of enemies so
it encourages you to stay in that given
area and like do different things here
and there like focus on different stuff
and you can take some time to sort of
look around a little bit more that said
the story the story is a little scanted
you know I think and the storytelling
like it feels to me like the mythologies
there and there's some like really
interesting pieces but they don't they
don't really come alive tie together
through the storytelling as I've
experienced it myself thus far yeah yeah
I I think I don't know Bungie to me like
I was never too wrapped up in the Halo
Mythos either but at least those games
never really took themselves too
seriously I feel like this is maybe like
diving into its Mythos a bit more but it
it's just kind of lame I don't know like
the story stuff I don't think is
particularly interesting whatsoever I
don't know yeah I think there's
something to be said about maybe the
story kind of really reaching right
because you have these heavy
sci-fi moments where they're they're
saying something really important like
oh you know this this looks like it
could be really bad but it's it's not
saying it in a sarcastic tone they're
being genuine but you almost want to
laugh because those are like very kitchy
sci-fi things that you see they're
cliche um but you forgive games in that
sense from it um like dinkle himself is
like this really interesting character
he's a fantastic actor but he's playing
a very serious role and does he play
that role the way that want him to a lot
of times I feel like that role itself is
like a problematic role because he's
saying very stereotyped things and he
has to say them very genuinely serious
he is exposition bot like the only
reason that guy is there is basically to
to take the replacement for menu text
like that's all he's doing that's right
but it's really hard for a a serious
actor to take that role and to do it the
way he did I feel like he got kind of a
bad he got a bad it doesn't even seem
like a role to me it just seems like
that's you know yeah just come here and
read these lines and yeah yeah why get
dinkle then I mean dink you've already
completed to clarify you've already
completed is this something you think
you're going to keep playing because
they clearly want people to be playing
this for we so it seems like beating the
story is just like step one so to speak
I'm curious right now just to see you
know is something going to unlock at 20
you know or are we just going to have to
walk around wander around and see the
rid I want to see what the raids are I
want to see what these materials I'm
picking up to craft stuff access the
raids yet or what
because your level I don't know I don't
currently there's like there's like
strike missions which you have to run
with a fire team of up to three people
and those are on every planet but the
stuff that Bungie's mentioned about six
player raids is is sort of the phrase
they've used uh I haven't been able to
see those I haven't seen any of those
well so to touch on that point it's like
Jeremy has gone back to the sewers like
in Old Russia where you know we've seen
the skulls the question mark guys and
he's like 15 16 and there's still
question mark skulls for him so maybe
it's like one of those like there's
there's areas little pockets like I see
areas where there kind of looks like
black smoke almost like there is a way
to get through there but they're not
letting you go through there now I'm
pretty sure those are enemy closets you
think so yeah game is full of monster
closet that is where the monsters come
from that's the darkness I mean they're
always talking about the darkness I
think like literally that that's they're
like uh how do we just put a closet in
this cave here oh the darkness great we
need Jackie esato to turn up and start
killing Italian Mobsters yeah great no
problem all right you want to go play
some video game all right let's do it
let's jump right so we're gonna jump
into a little bit of Crucible action
today this is uh my hunter uh EXO female
character uh which I'm starting to
actually I don't know if you can zoom in
on the anyways I'm starting to get some
gear that like looks cool as cooler as
well uh and I think that just sort of
reinforces my sort of feeling that get
get a little higher off up and then get
get cooler stuff yeah also to touch on
that that the touch on that note that
one gun that I was talking about you're
going to see in a second also has like a
little bit of an effect to it that all
the other guns don't seem to really kind
of have that kind of makes it look a
little bit more unique and that's not
even a legendary item like the purple
item so that's also another thing I want
to see I want to see how good these like
really really good items are so what's
the level of all the items there's uh it
starts off with regular like there's
clear common and then it's green green
orange purple standard MMO coloring is
uh rare yeah and then purple F yeah
legendary yeah yeah anyway we're going
to hop into The Crucible this is the
multiplayer aspect of Bo just join me
hop on in there uh this is I remember we
we played this stuff I just unlocked so
I just played so we basically this is uh
domination you capture an area and hold
it this is Team Deathmatch I just
unlocked this one and I'm trying to see
how this is different oh it's
free-for-all uh so we're going to go
into a team death match uh Tay and I
here and uh uh we'll see how it goes
that you had sort of had a glimpse of
the map earlier um we won't show too
much of that it's spoilery so oh really
well I mean it's you know it shows you
where Venus is and stuff like that it's
not that bad but uh what I will show is
I've I've hit level 15 now right and
that allows you within your class I'm a
Hunter uh to get your subass so this
Gunslinger Hub subass is that Golden Gun
one that I played with all yesterday
that we saw through the beta this one
now is the blade dancer subass which I
just unlocked the ability I'm not
actually sure how it works that well uh
charge your Blade with Arc lightning and
consume your foes with lightning so it's
a melee thing probably actually not the
one I want to use for uh oh you never
know like if if you're on a point and
you want to just go stabby stab sure
pretty I mean I'll use it because it'll
be fun and I'll try to stab people and I
definitely I find that in in the
competitive multiplayer for Destiny so
far I use different weapons than I do in
this in the I keep saying single player
but in the campaign campaign what you
call it anyways Outside The Crucible I
use different weapons than I would
inside so for example I prefer to use a
hand Cannon which is just a giant pistol
uh but inside The Crucible I use this
burst file I've been using this burst
file pulse rifle an auto rifle is also
really good uh it just like higher fire
rate seems to work in your advantage
also have this shotgun which is actually
not that great compared to my other
stuff but I'm not I'm no good at sniping
in like competitive matches so where
whereas I go with a sniper for sure
Outside The Crucible I go with a shotgun
here are you guys wai get into a game
yeah so I have a question for you Chris
so this is a load screen so actually
we're just arriving so this is the
screen you see before you get into any
match uh the poor moon when you when you
got your subass right yeah did you feel
like it was like is it pretty different
from your other class or yeah your other
class because for me one's very kind of
more offensive Centric and then the
other one's more defensive so I was just
curious if yours has like a noticeable
difference uh this one seems to be hello
can you see me in the window nope
didn't you got that guy face nice punch
me we're on the same team oh God I just
get a little touchy sometimes in the
multiple multip it wasn't you it was the
other guy also like a big key uh
important thing to note uh for
multiplayer is like trying to control
the heavy weapon ammo because like that
stuff Hurts the Most and so it only pops
up every now and then how many uh heavy
weapons are you allowed to have on you
at any one time so you choose your load
out coming in and that's why you
shouldn't actually go into The Crucible
until you get your first heavy weapon
there's there we were just at the heavy
is such a mass Advantage oh God I don't
know where anybody is what do you guys
mostly use then rocket launcher or
sniper or what I use the machine gun
machine gun yeah uh the there's the
rocket launcher and the Machine Gun are
the heavy weapons I've encountered uh
what do you guys know of any others I
use the machine gun primarily and it's
like stunningly more powerful than
anything else I own to the point where
like if there's ever a boss in campaign
mode or anything else you better have
heavy heavy ammo on
you multiplayer to not have it just see
like it would
be not just a disadvantage but a death
sentence yeah I mean cuz you're you know
you you actually don't you don't get it
too often cuz like Special ammo is the
green that I've been picking up and
that's basically your secondary weapon
my shotgun that pretty much anyone can
get you generally speaking like it's
it's pretty abundant but the purple ammo
the heavy weapon like I you pick that up
and you know even without being too
careful you can pretty easily go on a
spree Tay you've got one here what the
hell is this thing so this is that gun I
was talking about it's it's essentially
oh crap he just uses special on me um
yeah I got special I got caught in that
special as well it's a pulse rifle that
shoots almost like
Elemental bullets even though it's like
it's still AR bullets it's still your
normal like main weapon bullet but it
shoots like electric pulses there's
heavy weapon ammo by the way yeah I saw
it come up but then it disappeared which
means someone has it somewh over
here use it on a dude who you okay I'm
looking got that big ass gun use it to
murder some Space Magic Man there's so
much pressure thanks Annie Chris how you
finding this in relation to like you're
you've played a lot of Halo you're a big
halo fan uh obviously it's not like an
apples apples comparison but is there
any Crossover at all in terms of play
style floaty jumpiness and whatnot nice
work he is a little floaty but you have
uh you have a double jump and your
double jump you know depends on what
your class is uh
so oh off the Jump nope it's not jump
but I did get the double jump but I
didn't where's the capture Point Chris
there's no capture Point team dude okay
I
was my pretty much in any mode you just
kill the other people
though it's all kind of whatever all
right so I've got my machine gun now I'm
feeling a little bit cocky so not being
Oh's near you there's one near you yeah
I got
him that's straight up Tommy Gun yeah
space Tommy Gun Tommy really big space
rle like I'm so big I can't keep all my
bullets on my inside isn't that kind
that's one of the criticisms as well I
guess is that I I guess Eric the gun you
had there was was pretty interesting but
like largely we're basically looking at
space pistol space sniper rifle space
automatic rifle space Tommy Gun there
isn't there a sword at one stage yeah
but it's only for that one Mission oh
really so
it didn't finish me off oh God my health
is very low oh good I got caught on that
stupid little ledge uh progress from
this bleeds over into the comp stuff as
well right uh it does I mean XP right
you get XP and your XP is is shared but
there's no separate Crucible XP there is
a separate Crucible currency called uh
Crucible marks and like deuts marks yeah
it allows you to buy and level or get
gear that specifically is for The
Crucible okay uh so that's you buy
German soccer jerseys I don't know okay
you might I me can youy Angela Merkel
bobbleheads no there I have yet to
discover a bobblehead this is this after
all is not bored over thanks Bungie you
got to collect um items as well to
upgrade all your stuff I found that
interesting Chris that you were finding
that you were like taking apart other
items like uncommon or rare items to
obtain things that you needed yeah yeah
so for the hunter like to get some of
the bigger up some of the upgrades on
your weapons cuz once you get uncommon
and rare gear uh you can upgrade it and
which you got off their bike oh you use
the supercharge much in combat it must
be a lot harder than the campaign right
I definitely do I mean I haven't used
mine I am supercharged right now I
haven't used it yet because it's a melee
uh maybe I'll use you right now maybe
there's someone in here I can stab oh
this is weird I've never used this
before so I don't actually you have two
daggers I think it's just straight melee
come on someone come get the ammo
someone come get you get items in here
too I guess how long is it you're going
to find someone the minute it cools down
you know that I really am oh
buts sorry guys I really
tried any uh uh customization on the
weapons at all unlocks and stuff oh yeah
so I mean you know some of the unlocks
just cost a little bit of money some of
them actually cost marks uh you have to
use like materials as well and so you
can get materials from if only you had
your swords you suck magistrate death uh
if you can you know you use so like
you'll find gear you'll find like
materials in the world someone's got a
ship oh I just leveled up sweet
someone's got a ship though yeah uh so
that's why you might want to have a
rocket launcher we lost so there weapons
and turrets and stuff as well in that
particular level that particular level
has uh turrets and vehicles uh on the
moon that was moon right yeah on the
moon I'm not sure what it's actually
called I think on the moon uh that one
has that it has it in Domination as well
other Maps I've encountered on Team
Deathmatch I think I've played on like
three other Maps uh do not have vehicles
or turrets and that's another thing so
the game's got Vehicles right it's got
the sparrow which you Cruiser around on
your like land Speeder Bike I want I
want like more vehicle stuff or more
specific like it's just a point A to
point B thing and like you saw actually
we showed some some footage earlier
about of us like just going up this
really h t uh tall Dune and like
cruising off the top and that was fun
like that's kind of you make your own
fun stuff yeah but I feel like like uh
you know Borderlands with its multi and
and Halo with their multi-person
vehicles like the vehicle has a turret
on it like that is a lot of fun and it's
actually some good gameplay variety you
have to protect it you can like you can
face different enemies you can face
enemy Vehicles like that kind of thing I
feel like Destiny's riped for uh you
know especially with the sort of
sprawling areas but there's only two
right only seen two right after sand we
did see we we saw one of them one of
shoots rockets and then one that shoots
like laser Photon beams you mean another
vehicle yeah I've only seen two that can
actually fire yeah so you have to steal
those from enemies uh in um in the
campaign area but you can also in like
multiplayer maps on that
match matches on that map specifically
you can get them they were in the beta
uh yeah some shoot missiles they have
different kind of boost stuff like that
but I don't know like riding with your
buddy in a in a cars it's kind of weird
like I think we made the joke that it
would be cool to have a side car yeah
it's the same thing honestly with the
when you compare it to being gun crazy
like you can get car crazy too you want
to try them all you want to find them
all and we feel like we did and you want
so many different even you know ones
that have like particular boosts you
know that go incredibly fast but then
slow way down those are great for very
particular instances and the fact that
like just finding all these different
types of of vehicles is a huge addition
of the fun of the game of playing with
your friends holy crap look what I found
one of the funnest things when I was
playing yesterday was when Chris uh
stabbed a dude and took the pike vehicle
was the first time we had an enemy
vehicle and it was like one of those
moments when you play with your friends
when someone does something cool and all
the other guys go oh my God oh my God oh
my God and then like we found a bunch of
other Pike vehicles and I went oh my God
oh my God I feel like those moments
didn't come enough when we were playing
like yeah it only happened a few times
yeah that's those are like those amazing
stories that you play you know that you
tell your other friends when you play
when you play games like Borderlands
like and then we found the giant sword
and we got on this giant vehicle and we
destroyed the ogre and it's like I want
more of those
stories water's taking names got all the
names look at this no I came around
thought some dudes were on my back
little double to start things off not
too
shabby come on T let's do it let's do a
victory go team Crucible guys t uh you
obviously already completed the game uh
probably going to play a bunch more of
this over next couple weeks is this
Crucible stuff like are you interested
in keeping up with it or is it like a
farming tool just for the single player
at this stage uh I think I think it's
cool that you can use it as a means to
still level up I think that's something
a lot of of watch out what do you think
are you enjoying doing this stuff oh you
so I will after I get through the PVE
stuff like I want like that's always
been my focus like even when I played
wow or whatever I always cared more
about the PVP but or the PVE sorry but
that's me personally um I think it's
okay like I haven't Dove too deep into
this yet but I mean it's it's always
good to have a multiplayer well okay I
shouldn't say that it's good to have a
multiplayer if it's if it makes sense
like it makes sense to have a
multiplayer here right so you know when
thing I'm not super keen on in the
multiplayer is the health bars the enemy
health bars which appear over your
enemy's heads oh really oh yeah like
it's right I don't know just I I feel
like there are way better ways to handle
that oh God behind me that must be like
one of the first times that multiplayer
Shooters actually had enemy health bars
on it eat it come on I got a bunch of
questions coming here multi Shooters
don't really have that right oh God get
away Question Time H diversion on Twitch
what is the max level at the moment in
Destiny T what's the highest one you saw
I think 30 is the hard cap and then 20
is the like soft cap so to speak is what
I heard uh we saw that 24 yesterday yeah
we saw a level 24 player yesterday that
must have been a Dev right oh gotcha uh
ye yes because you know there's no
there's no way that we were playing like
with early copies yesterday so de
cheater a bunge player or an Activision
player or something like that over there
watch Bob Jones 98 asks do we know the
release date for the first expansion for
is December did someone say December
yesterday I don't know if that that's
just what I heard but I don't know if
that's actually dark below or whatever
actually correct oh we all know about
the dark below I don't even understand
your euphemism
sometimes that a poop one I don't know
how many maps are in this bat boy it can
be a poop one they can all be poop ones
if you really
want how many Maps uh I don't know
this uh this is a new map I have not
played on uh personally so maybe there's
five that I've seen hello friend this
this is a franchise that Bungie wants to
run for 10
years yeah well someone was asking me on
Twitter the other day like why is the
level cap so
low over there yeah well considering
like after a day Tay's already reached
over halfway and basically and beaten
story and yeah and like basically
already almost reached the the it better
be cool this time do it yeah get stabbed
you want to get stabbed too wo everyone
get stabbed we got stab party for
everybody someone shooting me behind me
I don't know where they are oh you got a
shotgun to the face but it didn't kill
you for some reason stoed them with
bullets go crazy got two stab kills at
least Y Sanchez asking a lot of question
people asking his question any PC
release date news no no nope has not
been announced nope won't even flirt
with that but I I'm sure they've heard
you if you're
curious keep badgering them like
everyone did with Rockstar they work oh
I upgraded I unlocked an upgrade for my
helmet I mean I assume it's just this is
a good time to look at that let's see
what upgrade I got for my it's impending
so now I can oh well it's an upgrade
that's becomes available to replenish
Health each time I pick up an or of
light but I have to get the previous
upgrade which requires some gear that I
don't have t you're supercharged I know
do something super cool I gotta do the
slam dunk move I gotta find someone
though it's probably not easy to land
either do these doors okay but even
yourself stop being so negative you got
this oh thanks you're not as terrible as
you think believe in yourself you idiot
believe
it boom I watch that that was good that
was really cool I think there's another
guy right you're so cool Eric thanks oh
no the door closed my grenade I got
Jinxed the door closed on I was going
for the Triple and then I blew it cuz I
had my shotgun out uh Sam
do you think Destiny is going to get
better with time or will it stay the
same that's a good question get better
with time I think it'll get better I
will more stuff to do they're going to I
don't know so far it's only gotten
better with time right I mean with our
time our first few hours we were like
all right we've done this before we've
seen it before um once you get into the
subass everyone starts getting really
excited that there's way more decisions
to be made I it's gotten that much
better I'm skep I'm skeptical personally
I like yeah any or any like franchise
that was required like is is really
thinking about having a 10-year lifespan
probably needs to have a stronger
Foundation than what we're seeing here
but you might never finish a strong
Foundation I think it's not come on drop
down in front of me like I like when
Gears of War I came out
like this game doesn't do anything new
and those types of franchises it's a
really polished much better version of
Borderlands with better shooting and
arguably actually probably worst story
like any game that like wants to have
that lasting of appeal I feel like it
actually has to shake the boat and do
something new like I guess you know
maybe wow you could say was similar but
like nobody's going Topsy Turvy over
this bad boy even people who are
enjoying it aren't saying this is this
is really really good well sure uh but I
mean is so is there that's a good point
like the kind of success that we've seen
from a game that is like immediately
just captures everyone's imagination and
sort of dazzles people with something
new or exciting right that's not the
kind of game that Destiny is proving to
be thus far so uh what kind of game is
it is there a different kind of nope
nope he's got his Golden Gun oh God
man's got
pul so that's not the kind of game
Destiny is at least for us here because
other people are having different
reactions other people are super I would
say that what what I was saying was was
a good median appreciation of what's
happening because even people I'm on
Twitter I was asking this morning who
who have pre-ordered it are saying yeah
it's it's it's they're laying the same
criticisms that we were yeah so that the
kind of success that a game like the
ones you mentioned has found Destiny may
not find so is there room for another
kind of success is there uh you know is
there sort of the long burn where like
just people keep talking about Destiny
and like oh I've played Destiny more
yeah I I'm really enjoying it the more I
play it like does that word of mouth
grow do do new expansion packs come
along and sort of reignite do they do
they find ways to attract people along
the way along the course of their sort
of 10year thing well let's let's lay
that up against something like
Borderlands which is a game that I like
people who were very much into
Borderlands are maybe looking forward to
the Pre-Sequel there's a bun which is a
lot of people but there's a bunch of
people who were just sick to death of it
like we look at where we at with
something at Call of Duty which is a you
know fantastic game well sorry sorry
sorry Cod forward fantastic game and
it's had fantastic games in it but they
are like struggling to reinvent that
thing at this
stage later yeah but it's going to have
to this a game to have that sort of
long-term success like kind of has to
sell quite a lot at the start and I'm
not I don't know well I guess we'll find
a number soon but like to me this is
Jew's out I sounds like you don't like a
lot of the marketing Spiel that you
heard Mar been watch reading games
magazines and going to websites long
enough to you know forget all that
nonsense to me it's like it's just it's
a it's a really competent game and they
spent half a billion on it and that's
where it doesn't add up for
me there's just so much left to be
discovered at this stage is there though
after a day tay completed the single
player yeah it could have been fast
uh how do you feel about it but I also
think that's not the way the game like I
said I am still cautiously I've always
been cautiously optimistic about this
game um because oh he just killed me but
anyways like I got to I want to see all
of it before I totally judge it but at
the same time it's been kind of
repetitive like a lot of the fights have
been kind of repetitive I want I wanted
cooler things like the sword fight and
all that stuff that we saw early didn't
really see that towards the latter part
of the game I'm kind of curious if the
raids stuff's going to get make it
better or not um but you're like you're
somebody who likes Diablo so it's not
it's
not you don't necessarily don't like
repetitive games what is it that like
this game's not Bo is ticking the loot
there's not that much loot uh I mean yes
there's going to be legendaries and
whatnot but the diversity of the guns
it's not that big there's not that many
special effects to the guns like it's
just like you have a pulse rifer rifle
you have a better pulse rifle you have a
sniper rifle you have a better sniper
rifle and like Diablo there's
many pieces of armor armors that will
change your your skills and whatnot like
and the thing is even with the skills
for um like your classes now a lot of
those aren't like active skills right
they're not things that you're doing
it's mainly shooting grenade like
grenade is like a skill like one of your
skills I guess um but it's stuff like
that like the the depth of this game it
just doesn't feel that deep it's like
you have you have a gun you're shooting
it's fun I mean it looks great it's fun
I just don't know how long it's going to
last for even someone that me like me
who like grinds a lot of stuff like oh
yeah like if they can tell me there's
going to be a special gun or if there
was even like a melee weapon that we
could have got like that not just our
fist or something like that that you can
get like that's cool but I don't know
that that's for me personally so I'm
optimistic about the game but at the
same time I'm kind of like H I'm kind of
feeling a little sketchy about how long
it's actually going to last for me for
me I don't know about anyone else uh I
feel like the way I am feeling about
Destiny now can kind of be sort of
summed up by the way I feel about
Destiny's storytelling right I feel I
sort of mentioned this before but I
think the the blocks of Mythology of
this this breed of aliens this breed of
aliens This calamity that happened this
world stuff like all that stuff is there
and it interests me but in a lot of ways
it's abstract I can only like observe it
I'm not like directly connected to it by
storytelling there's not something that
makes me necessarily care more about
more intrigued about one type of alien
than the other there's not a lot of sort
of direct access as the player in terms
of Storytelling at me to get it so while
I'm up I have seen enough that I'm
intrigued I'll probably stay with it a
little bit I totally get that like the
direct connection is not really there
and the story that the dinklebot like
that stuff is actually pretty flat and
it's pretty like cliche like you were
saying earlier Mary and so I I feel like
you know maybe that that immediacy of
experience that like you pick it up you
play it and like yeah like even
something like
where like at least in that you felt
like you were engaged in this world you
couldn't wait to you were chomping itap
some more like I never felt compelled to
go forward based on the story just or or
on the loot I was kind of just keep
playing because it was having fun with
friends Mass Effect for yeah yeah Mary
you going to keep playing this bot boy I
know you played a lot of Borderland yeah
I think I I think I will you know a lot
of these things that we're talking about
all these criticisms they're completely
legitimate and they they can affect
whether or not you want to pick up that
controller and try it again uh and time
and time again the reason that I do play
these types of games is to have really
funny awesome things happen with my
friends those holy [__] moments with a
group of buddies where something happens
that you know you couldn't believe would
actually happen I do think it can happen
in this game and that's kind of what
drives me back to it you know like one
of the issues we were finding was with
the with the dinkle B all the stories
are uh hey let's protect uh dinkle while
we uh we shoot all these bad guys while
he hacks something and that happens y
all the time all the time it's like this
consistent thing that happens that's
there's like zero Quest vary in this
game that's the one thing like that's
like a legitimate criticism I totally
agree and it's a bummer um I will
forgive that and I will forget forgive a
lot of other things every time you find
a massive sword and slice a dude in half
with it or when I find out that I can
pop a dude's head off um you know and
all this black [__] came out of his neck
like there's cool stuff that when they
happen and you get that sweet moment
that will forgive those criticisms but
the criticisms are legitimate yeah yeah
for sure all right go on all right just
last last thoughts for me it's just like
to hearken on her point one it's got
that Cod effect if your friends are
playing they're going to message you
you're going to play you're going to do
it um and the with the skill things
maybe we just haven't Dove deep enough
into them because like At first I
thought the subass for the Titan was
going to suck balls because it's just a
big Shield but I could see that being
used in spe very specific cases and it
could help you so this is very early
like yes I did technically beat the
story mode but maybe there's something
on the horizon I don't know well we've
had a 24 hours or more to to play it you
guys can play it right now it's
available on a bunch of platforms uh
every Xbox and Playstation you'd ever
want to still own yeah so let us know
what you guys think uh the review for
Destiny will be up later on the site we
have a review in progress that's up now
uh the video review in progress will be
up uh pretty soon as well Destiny
Destiny Destiny Destiny we will we be
talking about it in a month or two
months or three months or four months
from now I guess only time will tell
thanks very much for coming on the show
guys talking about Destiny hey let's not
talk about Destiny much next week let's
talk about other games like Canon brawl
and what else uh paper bound paper band
anything else that's it so far right uh
if you were one of the folks who entered
our competition yesterday on the live
stream H we'll be tweeting at the uh
we'll be getting in contact with you
over Twitter over the next couple of
days um uh just make sure you're still
following us so we can DM you uh and
yeah that's it go play Destiny or do
something else uh the review in progress
is going to be rolling right after the
show so if you want to stick around in
the Stream by all means do uh until next
week when the destiny is on same time 2
p.m. Destiny on destiny.com
Destiny
Destiny it's your
[Music]
destiny
now